اهلا بكم قال رئيس الوزراء الليبي الجديد
احمد معيتيق انه يريد التشاور مع جميع
القوى السياسيه لتشكيل حكومه ازمه وتفويض
بعض السلطات للمناطق جاء ذلك بعد جدل اثره
اختياره في المؤتمر الوطني العام نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين كيف سيتمكن معيتيق من خلق توافق
سياسي في ظل الجدل الذي اثره انتخابه في
المؤتمر الوطني وما هي الاوراق التي
يمتلكها للتصدي للتحديات الكثيره التي
تواجهها
البلاد ميلاد عسير اخر لرئيس وزراء جديد
في ليبيا
جلسه من الانقسامات والاختلافات في
المؤتمر الوطني العام انتجت اختيار احمد
معيتي في انتظار اختبار اصعب ربما عندما
يعرض وكما هو مقرر خلال اسبوعين طاقمه
الحكومي على
المؤتمر على مختلف الشؤون مع اعاده بناء
المؤسسات الامنيه والعسكريه والقضائيه
وضمان
فعاليتها صحيح ان الطريق امام الحكومه
المرتقبه برئاسه معتي ليس معبدا فالى جانب
انه يواجه منذ البدايه احتمالات الطعن في
دستوريه اختياره من قبل معارضيه فان عليه
العوده مجددا للمؤتمر الوطني بعد اسبوعين
ليطلب الثقه لحكومته وتلك عمليه قد لا
تكون سهله نظرا الى الجدل الذي احاط
باختياره العنوان البارز الذي يقرا في
الشارع الليبي وفق الاحداث الجاريه في
البلاد هو ان مهمه الحكومه اي حكومه ستكون
صعبه في اتجاهات كثيره تبدا بصعوبه
استيعاب المتناقضات الكثيره في البلاد ولا
تنتهي بتعقيد المساله الامنيه وكيفيه وزن
المعادلات المتعلقه بها في بلد مليء
بالاسلحه والميليشيات المسلحه والاتجاهات
الفكريه التي توجه المسلحين وفي ظل صراع
الاجندات المتضاربه في ليبيا تبقى فرص
نجاح متيج وحكومته القادمه رهينه الى حد
كبير بتحقيق الاختراق المقنع في مجمل
التحديات اولا بدعم الاغلبيه التي اختارته
لبرامجه دعما حقيقيا ثم بمصداقيه خطاب
حكومته ومدى صلته بتطلعات عامه الليبيين
ومع ذلك لا احد يستطيع في ظل المعطيات
المختلفه التي ظلت تعيشها ليبيا طيله
السنوات الماضيه التكهن بما سيحدث وان كان
كثيرون يعتقدون ان نجاح معتي يعتمد بشكل
كبير على عمق صلاته بالتيارات المؤثره على
الساحه الليبيه وعلى قدره وجراه طاقمه
الوزاري ومعنا في هذه الحلقه من طرابلس
علان المريف المجرف المقريف عفوا عضو
المؤتمر الوطني العام ومن بنغازي عبد
الجواد البدين الناشط في الحراك الفيدرالي
اهلا بضيفي لو بدانا بالسيد المقريف في
ترابلس السيد معيتيق مر بامتحان عسير
في المؤتمر الوطني العام رغم ذلك هل يمكن
له ان ينطلق بارضيه
صلبه نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اعتقد ان
يعني ل يعني الامر لم يكن سهل حقيقه ولكن
اعتقد ان امام
السيد احمد معيتيق الرئيس الوزراء المكلف
اي عمليه صعبه
ان مثل ما انتخبه الليبيين او انتخبه
اعضاء المؤتمر وهم يمثلون الليبيين في
داخل المؤتمر كان هناك توافق اجمع عليه
اجمعت عليه كل الكتل شبه توافق تام اي
عليه امامه مهمه صعبه وهو ان يجمع كل
الليبيين في هذه الحكومه ويجمع كل الاطياف
السياسيه في هذه الحكومه وهي هذه العمليه
ليست سهله حقيقه ا بعد هذه التفرق اللي
حصلت في ليبيا والمشاكل التي حصلت في
مناطق كثيره سواء في في المنطقه الشرقيه
وفي المنطقه الغربيه وفي المنطقه الجنوبيه
هناك حدود مفتوحه هناك امن منفد في في كل
ليبيا هناك مطالب من عده اماكن اعتقد
امامه عمليه صعبه ان يشكل الحكومه بطريقه
تضم الجميع ولكن ليست مستحيله انا اظن انه
سيخرج بحكومه تكون تكون مقبوله انا لست
هنا مدافعه على السيد احمد معيتيق ولا ولا
لا اتكلم باسم السيد احمد معيتيق ولكن
نتمنى مثل ما حصل الاتفاق في داخل المؤتمر
تمنى عليه او منه ان ياتي بحكومه توافقيه
حكومه تلم شمل الليبيين وتستطيع ان تقدم
ما يطم يطمح له الليبيين وهو اول اول نعم
سيد مقرف اشرت ال الى توافق شبه كامل ولكن
مع ذلك وهنا اسال سيد عبد الجواد البدين
عن السجال الذي اثير في في المؤتمر الوطني
العام بتقديرك هل سيؤثر على بدايات سيد
معيتك سيد
بدين ايوه نعم شكرا اخي الكريم وتحيه لك
والساده المشاهد
اظن ان الدخول الذي دخل به السيد احمد
معيتي الى مضمار السياسه كان دخولا غير
موفق يشبه الدخول من النافذه فنقول له
ليحسم هذا الامر وليعيد التصويت وليحسن
مساله الطعن الدستوري زملاء اصحابه في
المؤتمر يقولوا ان هو لم يحصل على ال 120
صوت المطلوبه للمصادقه على على على تكليفه
بهذه المهام ان رفعت الجلسه وانتهى
التصويت عند حصوله على 113 صوت وهذا قال
يعني كثير من الاعضاء الموجودين فلذلك نحن
نقول جرى تصويت اخر وحصل فيه على
121 هذا ما هذا ما تردد نعم اتمنى ان ان
يتم اتمنى ان يتم استضافه عضوين من اعضاء
المؤتمر او اكثر يعني من الطرفين يتم
استضافتهم ونسمع كلامهم وجها لوجه حتى
يعني نحن في بعض القنوات يخرج عضو واحد
فقط من طرف واحد او عضوين من طرف واحد
هناك طرفين الان في المؤتمر طرف يقول انه
لم يحصل الا على 113 صوت عند اقفال
التصويت وانتهاء التصويت الاستاذ عمر
بوليفه امس على قناه محليه وهو عضو في
المؤتمر الوطني على قناه ليبيا ليبيا تي
في صرح وقال ان باب المؤتمر كان مفتوحا
ومسموح للاعضاء بالدخول والخروج وهذه قد
تكون خرق ايضا في اليه التصويت يعني لو
كان دخل ناس بعد انتهاء 113 صوت يمكن ان
يزداد العدد اكثر من 113 صوت ممكن ان يتم
الاتصال باحد ويدخل ويضيف على ال 113 صوت
ما شاء يعني هذا هذه اليه اظن مطعون فيها
واليه متعقبه يعني ليست اليه صحيحه اللي
نتمناها نحن كليبين مراقبين للمشهد فلذلك
نحن نظن ان سالتني عن الدخول الذي دخل به
الاستاذ احمد معيتي اظن ان دخل دخول يشبه
الدخول من النافذه ولم يدخل من الباب
فنقول له ليكن موقفه اشجع واقوى مما عرض
حقيقه عرض علينا الاستاذ معيتيق رجل ضعيف
تسنده كتل سياسيه متغه في مفاصل الدوله
رجل مال وليس رجل سياسه اذا كان هو رجل
سياسه فعلا فعليه ان يرجع خطوه لوراء
ويطالب باعاده التصويت كما يطلب كثير من
الاعضاء من داخل المؤتمر نحن لا نريد
مشكله في الشارع الليبي تنبني
عليها مشاكل اعمق فلذلك نتمنى عليه ان
يطالب باعاده التصويت حتى فعلا نقول انه
دخل علينا من الباب فعلا فلذلك
الازمه موجوده الان اسمح لي سيد ببدين
اسمح لي اشرت الى انه دخل من النافذه وهنا
نريد ريد ان نعود للسيد مقريف لنطرح عليه
من جديد لانه واضح ان ضيفين على طرفي نقيض
في هذه النقطه طالما ان هناك اشكال سيد
المقريف في مدى الوجاهه الدستوريه
والقانونيه لبدايه سيد المقريف هل تعتقد
بان اصلا البدايه تحتاج الى تصحيح حتى
تكون الانطلاقه
صحيحه لا اعتقد انا اقدم احترامي وتحياتي
للسيد
دين العمليه الان هو من طعن في في في في
العمليه عمليه التصويت هم عليهم ان يثبتوا
هذا الشيء ان هذه مساله غير قانونيه هناك
كان في المؤتمر العدد كان يتجاوز ال30
تقريبا من طعن في ه في هذا التصويت هم
حوالي سته اشخاص هم عليهم ان يقدموا
الدليل وانا انا استطيع ان اقدم اقتراح
الان للسيد ليس سيد بدين لكن الاخوه الذين
طوا طعنوا في هذا كل جلسات المؤتمر مسجله
مسجله صوت وصوره يمكن تشكيل لجنه من
قانونيين من ليسوا من اعضاء المؤتمر ولكن
من اي قانونيين من اي جهه يراجعون
التسجيلات وسيتا كدون ان من صوتوا في داخل
القاعه اولا ان الجلسه لم ترفع هذه اول
نقطه حتى يتاكدوا منها الجميع ان الجلسه
قائمه هي جلسه واحده ليس جلس يعني لم لم
ترفع الجلسه ورجعنا لجلسه ثانيه هي جلسه
واحده وتم تصويت ب 121 صوت وبعد ما اعلنت
النتيجه انضم
شخصين من كتله التحالف
بالتحديد واضافوا اصواتهم فالمجموع 123
ولكن عندما اعلنت النتيجه كانت 121 فهذا
احنا متاكدين منه وهذا شيء قانوني ودستوري
الاخوه الذين طعنوا في هذه النتيجه من
حقهم ان يطعنوا فيها ادار هم هناك اجراءات
غير صحيحه وغير قانونيه ولكن عليهم ان
يثبتوا هذا الشيء والعمليه بسيطه جدا لا
تحتاج ان نعيد التصويت لان الاغلبيه مع
هذا التصويت ولم يخرج علينا اي احد من ال
1221 الذين صوتوا واعطوا اعطوا الثقه وانا
اؤكد لك شيء مهم من اعطوا الثقه في في في
جلسه ال اعطاء الثقه والتصويت على السيد
احمد ميتيك ليست من جهه واحده وليست من من
من كتله واحده كل الكتل كل الكتل وانا
اؤكد حتى من الكتله الراي المستقل وهي من
تطعن هي عدد كتله الراي المستقل
عددهم 11
شخص الذين طعنوا سته فقط منهم والبقيه
صوتوا واعطوا الثقه للسيد احمد
معيتيق سيد
مع بعد اذنك بعد اذنك سيد مقر سيد معيتي
طرح نفسه على انه رجل توافق واذا سالنا
سيد
البدين بانك وصفت رئيس الوزراء الجديد
بانه ضعيف وبانه رجل مال وليس رجل سياسه
كيف كيف يمكن اطلاق احكام مسبقه على رجل
لم يبدا حتى
في اظهار برنامجه او لم يحصل حتى على
الثقه على حكومته اليس ذلك بالامر
المتسرع هو قد يبدو بالامر المتسرع لمن لا
يعرف المشهد السياسي الليبي عن قرب واسمح
لي في هذا نحن نظن ان رجال السياسه اللي
طرحوا كمرشحين لراسه الز راء معروفين
واللي كان ممكن هو حضرته كان ويقولها يعني
ان هو رجل اعمال ويمتهن ويمتهن كيف ما
نقولوا ما يمتهن رجال الاعمال من ممارسه
التجاره وغير ذلك ف والذي يدلل على ذلك
ويعمق ذلك هو البرنامج الذي طرحه البرنامج
حقيقه لا يتوافق مع المشهد الليبي الحالي
البرنامج هناك ازمه حقيقيه في ليبيا وهناك
ازمه على اعتاب انتخاب البرلمان القادم
وهو مجلس النواب اذا كان انت عندك شهور
فلماذا تطرح هذه البرامج الطويله العريضه
التي تحتاج ممكن اقل شيء الى سنتين حتى
يرى الناس بعض ملامحها على ال على على
المشهد او في السطح خذ مثالا على ذلك
عندما تحدث ايضا لم يتحدث عن مساله حساسه
يعانيها الشعب الليبي وهي مساله الجيش
والشرطه لم نسمع هذا المصطلح في حسب علمي
لم نسمع ابدا مصطلح الجيش والشرطه على
لسان الاخ معيتيق انما هو على الاجهزه
الامنيه ودمج الاجهزه الامنيه وملف الا
الاجهزه الامنيه واعاده واعاده اظن ان
هناك اراده مهمه جدا موجوده عند هذه
الحكومه وهي ليست حكومه تصريف اعمال انما
هي حكومه تصريف اموال ستطلب ميزانيه كبيره
جدا لهذه الحكومه التي هي اقرب لحكومه
تصريف الاموال وليست لحكومه تصريف الاعمال
هناك ازمه سياسيه قائمه في المشهد الليبي
الان الوضع اعمق من كون انك تاتي بحكومه
لماذا السؤال لماذا تم الاستغناء عن
الثنيه ولماذا تم الضغط عل زيدان انا لست
مع الثني ولست مع زيدان وعارضه ما بشده
على كثير من المسائل التي ينفذون على ارض
الواقع من برامج لانهم حقيقه كانوا يهدرون
المال العام على كثير من الملفات مثل
الملفات اللي طرحها الاخ معيتيق هذه ابواب
لصرف المال العام انا اقول انه فعلا لو
كان حكومه لانقاذ هذا الوطن وحكومه لتصريف
الاعمال ليتها تكون حكومه لشيء واحد فقط
لايقاف النزيف في المال العام الليبي
لمحاسبه كل ووقف الكثير من الملفات التي
اللي هي ملفات ديوان المحاسبه وغير ذلك
محاسبه كثير من المسولين مسائل وهي مسائل
معقده سيد البدين ليس فقط المسائل
المتعلقه بالمال العام وانما ايضا المسائل
المتعلقه بال الوضع الامني وما تعيشه
البلاد من ما يبدو تمزق في في نسيج الوحده
الوطنيه على كل نريد ان نعرف بعد الفاصل
ما هي الاوراق التي يمتلكها السيد معيتي
لمواجهه كل هذه التحديات التي تواجهه في
منصبه الجديد لنا عوده بعد قليل نرجو ان
تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها مشاورات رئيس
الوزراء الليبي الجديد احمد معيتي مع
القوى السياسيه لتشكيل حكومه ازمه سيد
المقريف السيد معيتي
بدا بدا طموحا في حديثه عن الحكومه التي
سيشكلها وقال بانه يجب التشاور مع الجميع
وعدم اقصاء الجميع وحدد مجموعه ركائز هي
سيطره الدوله واعاده سياده وبناء المؤسسات
الامنيه والعسكريه وغيره هل تعتقد بانه
يملك الاوراق الكافيه التي تجعله بهذا
الطموح لا لا اعتقد ان في فتره الحكومه
الحاليه ان يستطيع
تحقيق هذه العناوين الكبيره التي طرحها في
في اول كلمه القاها امس ولكن نحن عند
عندما اعطينا الثقه للسيد احمد ميتيك
اعطيناه على حسب جدول او برنامج الحكومه
التي عرض علينا في داخل قبعه المؤتمر
الوطني العام عندما لمس اشياء وتلمس
الواقع الحقيقي بمعناه هو انه
سيساند مؤسسات الدوله الحقيقيه الان لم
يطلب ميزانيه لان الميزانيه هي ميزانيه
حددت من الحكومه السابقه ولكن المؤتمر ومع
الحكومه التس تسيل الاعمال الان تم
مناقشتها وتم تحديدها والميزانيه لاول مره
ستنزل بعد سنتين او ثلاثه الميزانيه
ستنخفض بشكل كبير لان انخفاض طبيعي لان
كان هناك صرف للمال العام في في اتجاهات
غير صحيحه ولكن السنه هذت ستكون ميزانيه
اقل كثير السيد لمس بعض النقاط الصحيحه
عندما تكلم على اصلاحات سريعه بمعناها
سيساند مؤسسات الشرطه والجيش وانا ا لا
اتكلم ما القاها الكلمه في التلفزيون امس
ولا تتكلم عندما تكلم لاعضاء المؤتمر في
داخل القبعه قال سا اساند مؤسسات الحاليه
هناك
مشاكل في مدن واضحه في في البنيه التحتيه
سواء في مدينه بنغازي او في طرابلس او في
المنطقه الجنوبيه في خلال 90 يوم سابدا في
اصلاح
هذه المشاكل الفوريه هذا ما ما كنا نريد
ان نسمع منه وهذا ما كنا نطمح اليه فهذا
وهذا ما ك ما نتمنى ان يطبقه انا لا انا
هنا لا اتكلم باسم السيد احمد الميتيك هذا
به وهذا ما سنحاسب عليه من برنامج للحكومه
نعم فيما يتعلق بالنقطه التي اشرت اليها
قبل قليل سيد بدين بان السيد معيتيق هو
رجل مال وليس رجل سياسه ربما تكون ما
رايته انت نقطه ضعف قد تكون نقطه قوه لان
ربما يكون الليبيون قد سئموا هؤلاء
السياسيين المؤدلجين سواء كانوا اسلاميين
او ليبراليين او غيرهم ربما رجل مال دون
خلفيه سياسيه مؤدلج مع تجربه اداريه جيده
يكون قادر على تسيير البلاد دون ان يكون
بالضروره مسنودا من تيار سياسي
معين نعم هذا ربما لكن ليس في الحاله التي
نعانيها الان نحن نعاني
من تكس وتكلس المشهد السياسي من داخل
المؤتمر هناك من يريد ان ياتينا باشخاص
عندهم علاقه به علاقه قرابه علاقه
قربه ويكون مظهره الخارجي ليس سياسيا وغير
معروف بشكل كبير لكن انا اؤكد انه قريب من
الكتل السياسيه وله علاقه بهم ولكن كان
تخصصه وما زال مالي نحن جربنا قبله جربنا
الكيب وهو من رجال الاموال ورجل صاحب
شركات وغيرها فلبيين لم يجربوا فعلا
السياسي المحترف صاحب التوافق الذي ينشد
السلم المجتمعي
وينشد التواصل بكافه المناطق في ليبيا
وبكافة من الحكومه ومن المؤتمر ايضا
ولكن الا يمكن ان
تكون جذور سيد السيد معيتيق هو من مصراته
الا يمكن ان يكون هذا رساله لبقيه المناطق
الليبيه ربما في اتجاه ان يكون التوجه في
المستقبل افضل من المرحله التي كنت تشير
اليها انا اسمح لي قد اخالفك الراي كثيرا
انا اظن ان هذه الرساله سيتم تلقيها من
الليبين بشكل معاكس مدينه مصراته مدينه
مجاهده وكان لها دور في هذه الثوره بشكل
جيد جدا ولكن بعد ذلك بعد نهايه الثوره
سياسيا خليني اني اسمح لنفسي ان اقول ان
مدينه مصراته كمدينه فشلت ان تسوق نفسها
سياسيا لكافه المدن الليبيه في فشل كبير
جدا الشاهد على ذلك غرغور والشاهد على ذلك
سرت والشاهد على ذلك كثير من المواقع اللي
هي تشهد على فشل حقيقي في ان المدينه
استطاعت ان تسوق نفسها لباقي الليبيين
سياسيا فانا اظن ان هذه نقطه ضعف وليست
نقطه قوه يعني سيد بدين هل هل لديك اي
تعليق حول هذا حول هذه النقطه تحديدا سيد
المقرف عفوا سيد المقرف
عفوا نعم نعم انا انا معلش انا اختلف مع
السيد مع السيد البدين
قليلا احنا اول اتهامات للمؤتمر وهذه هي
الاشكاليه من اول يوم بدانا فيه منداخل
المؤتمر وتوجهنا اتهامات بالكس و باتهامات
وهذه كلمه كولس هذه كلمه محليه نستخدمها
بمعناها وكانها بالمؤامرات ان ناتي بشخص
ونتامل حتى نصل اليهتم نسبه نسبه الى
الكواليس نسبه الى
الكواليس نعم ونحن نحن حقيقه كان امامنا
تقدم بطريقه شفافه حقيقه بطريقه شفافه
واضحه سبعه اشخاص حاولنا الان همنا كان هو
ان نصل الى شخص يستطيع ان يقدم خدمه
للمواطن البسيط الذي يحتاج مرتب في نهايه
الشهر ويحتاج الخدمات البسيطه ويحتاج امن
في نهايه انا شخصيا كان مرشحي شخص اخر
ولكن عندما تم الاتفاق على السيد احمد
معيتي ووصلت النتيجه انه هو من فاز فانا
من اعطيته الثقه مع مع الكثير من وصل الط
اعطاه الثقه لان نحنا في النهايه لا ننظر
ال الاشخاص ولكن ننظر الى ليبيا امامنا
وراينا ان المصلحه الان الا نقف العمليه
السياسيه وال واعطينا الثقه حتى تبدا
الحراك العمليه التنفيذيه يستطيع يقدم
حكومته ويقدم اتمنى ان تكون حكومه توافقيه
يجمع فيها الجميع ان نتكلم عن مدينه ما
ومدينه اخرى هذه امور اعتقد اتمنى اتمنى
ان لا تدخل البلاد في في صراع جهوي او او
مناطقي انا كنت اتمنى وانا كنت من دعى الى
هذه تمنيت ان يكون من منطقه معينه ولكن
ليس حب ليس تمسكا بها ولكن هذا طموح انا
انتمي الى منطقه من منطقه برك وتمنيت ان
يكون من تلك المنطقه و من ياتي من المنطقه
الغربيه يتمنى من هذه ولكن التمني شيء
والواقع والحقيقه شيء اخر
نعموا في النهايه اح قلب المصلحه المصلحه
وتكون ليبيا هي هي المصلحه الاولى انعم
سيد مقريف طالما نتحدث عن عن عن المناطق
سيد معيتي اشار الى تبني ربما سياسه اكثر
جراه في موضوع اللامركزيه هل هذا سيعطيه
نقطه قوه في المرحله المقبله اذا طبعا نال
الثقه او الحكومه نالت الثقه بالاحرى نعم
سياسه اللامركزيه بدا المؤتمر المؤتمر
الوطني العام اشرف واصدر القوانين و
والحمد لله الان المجالس البلديات تنتخب
في كل ليبيا واعتقد على ما شاف ان تنتهي
الانتخابات في كل مدينه بنغازي انتخب فيها
في مدينه الدابيه ومناطق كثيره وطرابلس
قريبا الان اصدرنا قرار في داخل المؤتمر
الوطني جزء كبير من ميزانيه الدوله ستذهب
الى البلديات هذا جزء من لام مركزيه احنا
لا نريد المركزيه انا اتي انا من مدينه
بنغازي ومدينه بنغازي من المدن التي همشت
في عاد القدافي ف ف فنريد هذه الميزانيه
تذهب الى مدينتي تذهب مدينه الجاره لمدينه
بنغازي يتحسن الوضع ولا يوجد اي طريقه
لتمكين المدن من التطور والتحسن الا
باعطاء الميزانيات للجهه المحليه وهذا ما
اعتمدناه وهذا ما سنعمل به وهذا ما يجب ان
يعمل به سيد احممد معيدي نعم هل هل هل هذا
بعد اذك سي من المتم الوطي العا نعم هل
هذا يمكن سيد عبد الجواد البدين هل يمكن
ان ان يشكل هذا التوجه نحو ال مركزيه نقطه
قوه وورقه قويه في يد السيد معيتي ليجمع
اقصى ما يمكن من الاجماع الوطني
حوله اظن انها كلمه اسمح لي ان اقول انها
لدغدغة
يعطي مدينه بنغازي والمدن اللي حدثت فيها
انتخابات يستطيع ان يعطيها 2 مليار او
مليار ونص مثلا هل يستطيع ان يصرف لها
ميزانيتها هل يوجد في في بنود ميزانيته ما
يخوله ان يفعل ذلك انا اقول انه كلام
للتسويق فقط ومحاوله لم اكبر قدر من
التوافق على حضرته في هذه المرحله اللي
يحتاج فيها الى الى الاسناد يعني ايضا سيد
البدين سيد معيتيق اشير اليه بانه قريب من
الاسلاميين في
حين البعض يشير الى ان لا صحه لهذا الخبر
وان لا انتماء ايديولوجي له هل تعتقد بان
ربما هي هذه ايضا احدى نقاط القوه التي
يستطيع من خلالها ان يجعل الكل يلتف حوله
في المرحله
المقبله اذا كان تقصد
بالكل التعريف الكل هي ل جنسيه لاشخاص
معينين في المؤتمر او كذا ممكن لكن اظن ان
الاسلام السياسي في ليبيا في تراجع كبير
جدا الشعب الليبي سائم كثير من المراوغات
اللي موجوده من الاسلام السياسي وخير شاهد
على ذلك ما فعله اعضاء المؤتمر المحسوبين
على الاسلام السياسي في هذه المرحله
الحساسه من انتخاب رئيس حكومه هناك قيمه
اسمها العدل تم طحنها وسحقها في المؤتمر
وايضا في الحكومه الليبيه طي الفترات
السابقه هناك ناس يتكلمون باسم الثوره
واحتكر الثوره لانفسهم هم اصحاب الاسلام
السياسي لا يوجد لهم زملاء كانها ليس ليس
لهم زملاء في هذه الثوره حتى من غيرهم من
التيارات الاخرى تهجموا و وطع انوا في
وطنيه وفي انتماء كثير من الناس اللي ما
ينمو الاسلام السياسي حقيقه الاسلام
السياسي في ليبيا في تراجع كبير ومستمر لم
يتلافى نفسه فلما بتسوق معيتق على انه له
علاقه بالاسلام السياسي هذه ايضا نقطه ضعف
ولست قوه الان في المشهد الليبي يعني شكرا
لك السيد عبد الجواد البدين الناشط في
الحراك الفيدرالي كنت معنا من بنغازي شكرا
لضيفنا من طرابلس ايضا السيد علاء المقريف
عضو المؤتمر الوطني العام وبهذا مشاهدينا
نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء خبر غدا باذن الله قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
استودعكم